susannah is with us in Los Angeles hi
Susanna how are you thank you for taking
my call
sure what's up in your world oh my god
it's a mess I am in a big you know
problem here I have a lot of debt we
were doing good my husband was making
enough to cover all of our expenses but
unfortunately he started using drugs so
now it's been two years and he's home
this right now and I'm in charge of
paying everything I'm not making it I'm
just I don't know what to do baby girl
you said he's homeless so you kicked him
out Oh
bad news so so basically you are are you
have kid any kids
once 18 but she's going to school the
other ones 15 and I have a six-month-old
that I'm adopting you adopted a child in
the middle of all this mess well yeah
it's my cousin so foster parent gotcha
okay yeah so when I assume you're
working yes and what is your income
$6,500 a year no sixteen sixteen
thousand five hundred dollars of you
okay and what do you do you work in 40
hours yes really
okay yeah and making not even hardly
minimum wage then okay and how much dad
have you guys got I have about 45 I want
to say that doesn't that's including a
car payment no how much do
on the car 15 okay and what's the other
30,000 and death unfortunately that was
the only option at that moment that I
sought to cover how long it wasn't the
only option was the one you chose what
how long has he been gone about a year
so he's gone yeah you're done okay
when will the divorce be final I'm
actually divorced now okay good okay oh
all right so what you have more than
anything else as you already know is you
have an income crisis yes you're living
below the poverty level because of your
income
and how old are you okay and how far did
you go in education high school college
what high school that's it high school
graduate and you're 38 okay and is your
family all in the immediate area there
where you live okay all right so here's
what you've got to do short term you've
got to get your income up and long-term
you got to get your income up this is
not this is mathematically not going to
get better until we do that that's where
your crisis point is all right and so
we're looking at extra work of some kind
on the short term and the long term
starting to think about what do I want
to be when I'm 48 that makes a hundred
thousand a year don't want to be an ER
nurse do I want to sell real estate
do I want to dot dot dot you fill in the
blank and then you start doing what it
takes to get there over the next ten
years and get your income all the way up
from this point in the meantime we got
to get your income up short term by
cleaning houses delivering pizzas I
don't know what all and the 18 year olds
gonna have to jump in and help with
care of the six-month-old and maybe some
of the other family members are -
there's we've got to get your income
moving here in order to get this fixed
and of course when you do all of that
you're gonna realize this is a car you
absolutely cannot afford this $15,000
car is gonna kill you in the process but
more important than getting rid of the
car is getting the income up hang on I'm
gonna have Kelly pick up we're gonna get
you in Financial Peace University and
help you this is the Dave Ramsey show
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh